[Evans] For this quiz, which is an especially udacious one,
your goal is to define a procedure, named measure_udacity,
that takes as its input a list of strings
and outputs a number that is a count of the number of elements in the input list
that start with the letter U, where U has to be upper case
since lower case Us are not quite udacious enough for us.
For example, if we evaluated measure_udacity passing in as input
the list containing the strings Dave, Sebastian, and Katy,
the result would unfortunately be a 0
since none of those strings start with an upper case U.
If we instead passed in the list containing the strings Umika and Umberto,
the result would be 2 since we have 2 strings that both start with the capital letter U.
See if you can define the procedure measure_udacity.
I can't claim that this will be a really useful procedure,
but it will be a good test of whether you understand how to use a for-loop
to go through the elements of a list.